Good morning, good evening, good afternoon, what what the heck were these bases wait
Minestrone those are clearly the bases that Mercy used on her stream
uh no what are you talking about these are completely clear base models that we
can utilize for African mystic
erodia gothani san erodia gothani san erodia gothani san erodia gothani san
pretty please with sugar on top make her gothani hop employee of the month thank you
oh you're you're welcome thank you for that hold on i'm just looking at stream elements my stream
elements has disappeared i can't forget here thank you raven for the tip you won erud erudere
hold on erudere i might have actually put the request on you know that
erudere erudere are characters who who pretend to be erotic at first but after falling in love
start to be more pure innocent and romantic isn't that the one where she looks like a fiendish thank
you for becoming a mim i am having schizophrenia i said thank you for becoming a member yesterday
to you
oh are you going to again thank you for becoming a member um isn't that the bimbo
application to wife material thing where she like drops the book and picks it up and then
she's like a wife by the end of it is that what you're asking congrats on a living k i got a living
k stop have i not not you're lying i only sell what i only celebrated 10k yesterday
or was it the day before i haven't slept i'm so sorry i don't know what day we're on
what how am i 11 000 that's insane thank you everyone for subscribing and liking and interacting
oh my gosh that clip we were in reverse bimbo application honestly right we will do pure right
let's see what your suggestion was let me reread it okay goth make her goth i hop employee of the
month right okay but you never said body type so we totally don't have a zura here you can pick
between regular a lollipop this is supposed to be milk but look i'll just i'll clean it up a
little bit okay let me just click this totally isn't she be what do you mean this is her hair
drills stop it what are you talking about yeah the the bases are by mersey i give credit to
mersey shawnee's is so much that honestly the desert look what do you mean this is clearly emmy
no it's not you're teasing me andrew scarlett thank you for the extended membership you deserve it
you're the best moment oh thank you everything are we already kissing at the start of stream
we're not supposed to but i couldn't help myself we just have to grab your little face
uh right okay so we've got goth i hop employee of the month and the term you want me to use is
erudere goth oni san uh you're literally just asking for my alternative outfit uh and i do like
to be seen as a big sister so twin race this is our problem what body type though what what do we
want for the body type on the goth big sister is it my body type or is it shebe's body type
are you squiddin me right now are you oh no i'm still doing the suggestion
strongly oh anon thank you i love anon i love refilling i don't know what variation
you're right now only somebody type mersey or shebe ester and ember also top tier
i like the way brian said in shebe question about shebe okay we're gonna wait wait why can i not
like move this over hold on sorry it's really not liking this right now what do you mean ms
paint is getting a bit old no don't say such things okay as long as you can see it on stream okay
we're gonna do goth i hop employee okay but yes i'm open to suggestions now do you want me to do
all five suggestions first and like we'll pick one for the body types and then we'll start drawing
or do you want me to pick draw pick draw pick draw pick draw how do you want it it's all in your
hands baby yeah i was hanging out in ac stream she's trying to she's trying for the life of her to do
um uh like childhood talk stream she she hasn't done one thing she actually only showed a part of
her childhood at the start of streaming that's it make her look like she eats an i-hop six pack
every hour what's an i-hop i assume that just means six pancakes in the stack actually pick draw
pick draw pick all five first oh god you guys are gonna you guys need to azura's neck no what are you
taught that's not azura what what makes you think this is azura that's bizarre like i honestly have
no clue why you think this would be azura at all like it it's actually kind of i don't know i feel
like you're being stereotypical here what are you talking about ruthlyn see it's not azura at all
see is anyone buying this yet or anyone buying what i'm selling pull you want to pull um i have to go
here to do the pull start pull how do we do this pick draw pick draw pick draw draw draw
eh no sorry pick all then draw start pull i'll just clear up the not azura by the way
oh my god clearly i can't color in between the lines of the child
we did it this is no longer azura and we have undeniable proof it's not azura
whoa you guys are getting kind of close to being a split okay pick draw pick draw pick draw i look
like okay i'm gonna sip my tea but good morning hope you guys are having fun i've tried to upload
all of my streams for this week youtube is having a hissy fit so they're all at the wrong time and
stuff but i have picked my um little i have picked what i'm gonna do this week how long does it take
to draw well considering i have absolutely no um hours behind drawing i don't know how long this
is gonna take i have no idea what i'm doing i'm just here for a good time but i've got goth eye hop
right here right what have you decided pick draw pick draw pick draw all right okay you guys have
decided guys have decided right let me slurp my tea okay so the first things first you need to pick
the three colors that go behind the design okay so you guys have said goth eye hop is eye hop's
logo red yeah is eye hop's logo red my brain wants to say it's red yes or no be be honest
good afternoon hope your day's going great my day hasn't even ended yet i have not slept
there's a new development behind the scenes and i can't even leak it i of course the eye hop is
it's like blue and white it's blue and white a blue and white goth so blue
white and black for the goth okay so this is our little color palette that we get to pull from
it's blue with red accents okay and then obviously because it's goth we have to do black
so this is our color scheme developed now for a cheeky goth um okay there's a little red uh
maybe maybe i'll do a red god i'm returning into france over here steady on
okay so for our totally not she be design um for our pupil let's start with the pupil
she is a goth goths are known for how dark they are what's a dark pupil that we could make i have
no idea so first let's do the pupil that's the most important part of a veal or design because
we do not have like a default pupil oh god that's so squiggly let's give her eyelashes oh you're
so kawaii ooh lovely oh my god you're such a beautiful girl uh an american god did you at least
get a good nap no i got like 30 minutes why no slime girls i think we're probably going to be
designing a slime girl i think we're probably going to be designing a slime girl red red white
and blue goths are known for their love of kenny from south park vampire bat shape i think a goth
would be cross an upside down cross maybe now your pupils really cannot be black well actually
no that's exactly what color the pupils are they are normally black but for a vtuber it's not like
how you're supposed to do it oh strani what do you know about development fuck all i don't draw i just
like you just can what looks good so we're just gonna do a darker hue on the outer side of her
eyes like that and then for the cross should we do it black i mean we could get away with it being
black a little upside down cross like this for the oh that's that looks like a plus sign try again
he won't strong it there we go upside down cross for the pupils and then it would have like the
accent of um oh maybe no that looks too silly okay it would just have like a little white
highlight around it i'm covering up the black note you know what i'm trying to do right you guys can
do this right yes for the slime girl you have to pick what body type you can have milk you can
have regular or you can have a lollipop on the slime but you guys can we'll do that after we've
designed our little une san okay so we've got our pupil type already fantastic um if she is her big
sister i don't normally see um how the fuck do i zoom in oh hold on hold on i'll pause this
stuff there we go boom zoom in like this um oh that looks even worse zoomed in who thought of
this stream i mean it was me but it's even worse than i imagined okay so now we need to transplant
her eyes on right so when it comes to anime the eyes are like down here okay so don't be
fooled the eyes need to start like all the way down here it looks weird right okay why did it wiggle
don't wiggle please don't wiggle no right don't do it that way don't do the actual circle so this
is une san is she a smoker if she's a goth she would smoke right we'll do a little ciggy hanging
out of her mouth at least cigarette cigarette was it is it brown at the bottom yeah brown at the
bottom where the filter is and then she's got like a little a little smoke thing you want red lipstick
oh i guess for the accent yeah oh maybe she has like she always has like little kissed cigarettes
around her this looks awful now you see why i literally do not design these girls
this is awful okay so that's sorry i'm completely like messing this up as well
you never saw a cigarette before i don't i have seen them but i don't smoke so it makes it harder
to imagine what i'm supposed to do at this stage okay then upside down cross oh my god she's gonna
look like a muppet do i look like a muppet to you i mean a little bit oh god i need to zoom in even
more oh my god this is like i don't want to zoom i'm getting scared to zoom in it looks scarier
she's oh she's looking like a clown you know that oh this is
are you squinting me right now oh his idea was this black lipstick also requesting to redest
her and ender on the dare types fandom wiki really wish we could have both at the same time or if
she could alternate between the two so you want her to have multiple personality disorder coming
right up i'm sure i can find a feature over that no problem okay we're gonna give her a little wee
white eyeliner thing okay and then for the hair now if you are emo real one of being emo or anything
you you require bangs of some kind it doesn't matter what they are you require bangs of some kind
so we have four points to her eyes so i'm going to give her so i've got three bangs like if you if
you count above my eyeballs there's three oh thank you for this strong if you want to find the person
who keeps making you do all these bad ideas just look in the mirror tell us how the fight went
afterwards oh my god that's just thank you thank you raven for the tip again and then thank you tiny
spiny for insulting me to my face rude you know i'll actually say one thing i submitted for
something like this i didn't get it back but i submitted so she needs four say that's three that
i'm just drawing myself god damn it wait hold on four how'd i get four that's five what but that's
three so how did i get four five one two three four oh that's four hold on a minute hold on a
minute i can't can't right she would have bangs no it can't go over her eyes because that's like
real number one of each of her so one bang two three four god i am special okay well right if she's
emo i hop so she would serve so she would have a cap on right like one of them those caps how do
you draw a cap i don't know i don't know how to draw a cap okay we take off her top of their head
i'm so sorry bowl haircut no hold on let it develop right so she'd be wearing a cap right
those like those hats that like come like this right and it would say i hop but because it's
your inappropriate onesans she was i hop on yo don't worry the algorithm can't read that okay and
then for the back of her hair what would we do some kind of i don't know let's get rid of the
cigarette smoke mr. cigarette you're in her way i will remove you at once thank you okay but for
her hair if she's got she needs like intricate like multiple things like coming out but what maybe
first do like the little no tell you what tell you what no hold on this went from chat giving strong
ideas to roasting the process give her twin tails but i'm biased towards twin tails i love i love
symmetrical hair like that i'm gonna make her asymmetrical on purpose okay so one side is gonna
be a bunch that come oh my god this is awful that comes out right and it's super duper long
because she's so edgy like that yeah she's just such an edgy onesan okay and then it's gonna be black
i'm so sorry she'd be here it's gonna be black but she's gonna have like the classic like oh this is
an asian in a in a video game let's give her a random purple streak and then for her bangs
she's gonna have purple blue on the outside only yeah yeah okay but then on the other side this is
the hideous most disgusting ugliest character design i've ever seen okay so one side is that
and then the other side oh no please see jim leader sabrina from pokemon find inspiration
jam leader sabrina okay i'm unironically looking the operate now i don't know how to do here
is she got asymmetrical here no that's not eight well it's kind of well no it's just long
so what should wait so if one side is a pom pom what the others
how did people design stuff oh my god i'm not being funny but how do you design stuff
this is hit this is awful
no wonder this shit costs like hundreds of thousands
how do you come out how do you envision what the freaking process is well hang it on the fridge
i like to think that these are references that stony said no i absolutely did not send us
normally with the research right let me finish my tea the hands right you know what
she's just gonna have one ponytail because i can't even figure it out i'll give her like
i don't know that like those bangs that come at the side though i don't know do we give her
like a little wing right no no we'll just give her bangs at the side so every artist can skip
drawn the ears because if you have ears the artist doesn't like it right and then we'll just connect
her neck again so she can breathe but she is smoking okay right and then for the outfit so
goth i hop so actually we want to fully shirt her up so we'll give her a collar right let's give
you that yeah that's right put that shirt on oh you're so beautiful with the shirt and then
but it will be a tight fit and form shirt okay so hear me out but
but she's purposefully tight wait i'm just drawn sheebie again fuck
i'm just drawn sheebie no right and then we'll show off her lovely arms because i like when
the uniform shows off the arms like mm-hmm your arms are so pretty onee-san oh my god onee-san
i can't control it that hurts would i do onee-san i've never had this problem before
please look after it why no slime girls i'm drawing one relax if i freaking read slime girl
one more time i'm gonna fart in your mouth please i will draw one i will draw one for the meme but
please don't expect a freaking slime girl i'm so serious right and then then she needs her logo
on her booba and it says i hop oh wait no it would have her name on it what would do oh sugar
what's your name a goth i hop a goth i hop what would you be called something emo
what's an emo name you guys got an emo name so supposed to be a threat to it you won't
what about exposed shoulder um
um where's slime girl up my arse it's i've no drawn it yet relax karen karen's not a goth name
what's the name of that goth from pokemon that everyone faps the sorry i shouldn't see
things so directly was it goth from pokemon hot hey hex maniac yeah okay let's just call her hex
because she's such a poser she's called hex and she says please have with me right kelly no marina
her name is dark right her name's hex okay we've got a name hex i don't know what her surname would be
hex hex flex oh my god wait no dark ross are you squid me right now
marnie please for the love of all that is holy and good in this world do not forget about the
brown piercing are you on it you're fissioness and black bdsm collar and cuffs oh well like
maybe just on top of her uniform she has like one of those collars that are infinite collars like this
and it hangs above her uniform and she doesn't take it off because you secretly gave her it
that's would you do a slime girl for gen 2 if i sent you three cans of Pringles
no you couldn't even pay me for a slime girl i'm not even kidding someone could like
fucking wallop their cock on the desk right now with like a fat 1000 us dollars you will not convince
me to have a slime girl i am not debuffing someone so harshly okay it is paramount that
her left eyebrow has a piercing it must be visually it her right but visually our left okay
visually our left but it's her right because she's always right we kneel for our big sister
it's can of Pringles thank you anonymous can of fucking Pringles fucking shovel can of Pringles
up your arse right Raven thank you for your tip and what you want to call her Hicks marina
what about four cans of Pringles anonymous stop it young man so the price is how much no there's
no i i'm not giving someone a slime girl debuff at least if i like someone wants an alternative
sure but i'm not giving someone a slime debuff the the gimmick of a slime disappears after about
20 seconds okay i don't care what you say we're about to draw a slime girl together and i'm going
to prove to you that the debuff is like so quick right i want it to be like really like this is
this button is ready to pop i don't know if you guys have seen sin sister's very unique toggle
but this shirt is ready to pop okay do i make myself clear okay and then we just need to connect
the shirt because that's how shirts work okay beautiful stunning now now what okay pan i mean
it's really rare for v-tubers to have a shorts in general so honestly i am down for shorts like
emmy has we shorts i don't know i actually wouldn't mind the kind of like covered up thingy and then
we do the fishnets what's that i'm going to manually draw fishnets oh you bet your you
bet your ass i am that's right because we're using ms paint that if you think this stream is painful
now you just wait until we start drawing the slime girl i am drawing directly on top of these bases
and there's nothing you can do about it manually pop that like behind me hi mommy sorry i'm late
ah i don't be silly not late right oh wait hold on no we're doing full body fishnets like i um sorry
we're doing full bottom fishnets so the fishnets are viewable up here above her thing hold on let me
just let me just swing my cock around because the fishnets would go above the shorts as well
just to really solidify that she's emo and it's not it's not it's not a phase mom okay
and then we do it this way and just like that we have created new fishnets
what's that this is the cringiest design you've ever seen and it's the most basic one yeah what
you're gonna do for it yeah you're gonna love it aren't you and then when gen two does actually get
revealed you guys are gonna laugh even harder looking at these because i already know what gen
two look like and you do not there we go and then if you didn't know at the end of a taste there's
like a woman is racist you she hates slime girls oh i didn't know where you were going with that and
i was like excuse me refling i thought you were actually calling i was like excuse me right okay
it's fine thank you for the tip anonymous i'm drawing i'm drawing a slime okay you you have
bullied me into submission i am drawing a slime after this one so the slime accusations can disappear
okay and then no one can call me slay mist again okay i believe in non osmosis supremacy okay if
you didn't know osmosis is a high concentration gradient to a low low concentration gradient
high concentration there concentration i can't remember what was mean yours okay and then we
did a little tool thing there's a little tool thing at the end of the fishnet
okay fishnets are almost done we're almost there
um we need to do the buttons on the shorts i love when the shorts have the buttons
i know she sits on her shorts funny because that button hits her button real good
stop it it's like first thing in the morning i have not slept so i'm extra delirious honestly
right i love when the shorts do that thing where it's like this and then it has a button here and
then it goes along and then like that oh well i guess that's the top of the shorts
no okay are you squiddin me right now are you squiddin me right now suggestions black thong strings
on her hips fishnet cell book gloves black handcuffs and ankle restraints black lipstick
one tiny black heart under just one eye black heart shaped pupils no i'm sticking with my
shitty pupils i've already decided right i'll take the heart piercing heart it's very clear
that she's also pierced in a few other regions for no particular reason i'm just making sure i've
got the shirt detail correct yep um how the fuck are belly piercings how do belly buttons
piercings work i actually don't know like is that a line no it's not a line it goes in the skin
okay she's also pierced in another region because you know she kind of freaky like that but uh you
can't get a toe piercing so that doesn't count um i actually controversially like the short
fishnet gloves i think because of the contrast that would play with the long leg fishnets
and then the glove very it's very short glove variation almost as if she's
like willing to touch you and you crave what you can get through the fishnet because if it was like
full length it's like oh the touch isn't as you know deep but it's deep uh i think maybe we'll
give her long black nails as well like classic long black nails i think that would do quite well
because like i mean come on be honest oh look at that come on don't you oh wait no hold on we'll
make her nails the same colors her eyeballs oh my god this is we're doing it i love piercings
because they taste like coins and i'm all about the money why why that's hilarious okay but she has
like longer fingernails like coffin shape if any of you guys know what coffin shape nails are you're
a real one she got oh who i keep disappearing off to someone else what do you mean drawing on ms
paint isn't a valid way to create an entire feature remote what are you talking about honestly right
for the the shorts there's not really much detail to it beyond what meets the eye should they be
short or um maybe they should be shorter in the fishnet raised up
uh okay okay i think they should be raised up let's raise them up
what what do you mean i'm delirious because i've not had enough sleep i have no idea what you're
talking about you are crazy whoa that's not how to erase something i guess we have to color in her
legs honestly i mean i'll take it it's fine i was gonna suggest that but i don't know coffin nails
are the best oh yeah we shadow wizard money game we love coffin okay our little and then
and then her model oh my god then her catchphrase is gonna be um her catchphrase if i can get it out
is gonna be why does it her catchphrase is gonna be let me serve you okay but obviously it's like
the winky face kind like excellent excellent let me serve you yeah like that kind of thing
what country do you come from a country called scotland forever okay this is the
shitest design ever okay well there she is so oh god is that really it is that oh i've got to offer
this world oh it's awful right her name's hex could you get any more stereotypical
there's nothing to the design i'll take it though i'll i think that's okay i would give this design
i would rate it great out of basic did you know ms paint has layers oh does it actually
that probably would have anyway uh i'm just gonna bring her to life because you know wait can i
can i oh i don't know how i did it but i managed to close the gap on the eyeballs okay right
yes i mean that's all we can do
because i don't have anything else to add to her we have done goth i hop employee of the month
ero dere goth nisan and then uh her name's hex her pupil is an upside down cross with
white outlines to it um she wears an infinity collar but it's actually secretly your infinity
collar that you gave her and then she says let me serve you winky face xoxo and she has a smoke
and addiction and she's got piercings out the wazo um aren't we being a little extra she can't be
barefoot i mean uh in the house she can because you know you share a house i mean i wouldn't put
her in heels servers don't wear heel heels servers wear trainers because it's too sore
literally i have formed this dick what you want me to put in james i'll put in james right now don't
think i want shorter nails because she works in the food industry and only son needs to be able
to properly take care of her darling brother's prostate health daily you said you said that part
i'll load again raven you said that part thank you for the tip now i'll let you in on a little
secret about the service industry if you are just a waitress and all you have to do is hold the little
tree of food and drinks i have fantastic news you can have long nails if however you prepare things
as a waitress you cannot have long nails because you're preparing food but if you're only doing
the serving and the gathering like that and dempo is a genia can you make a really sexy
sweaty mean chubby mum i mean i think that's all i can do with our beloved hex so we'll move on to
the next right you guys pick a body type for the slime you have three body types pick and it's totally
not between azura strongy or a super body type we'd long here nails mix up no depends if you're
using a server tree they could just be press-ons real real and true wrist and ankle cuffs like a
bracelet as you can tell i'm not very good at imagining and she's got one shoe because i gave
up halfway through making this shoe azura strongy do a poll oh yes of course we can do a poll don't
be so silly hold on let me do a poll start poll slain is what body type azuras strong wild card
sorry i see let's go leave azura alone we can think of something better you don't want slime
azura
um right i'm getting the slime out of the way and then after that anymore slain mentions oh my god
that's awful that's awful yeah this is why i literally do not create uh virtual models
oh wow you want a milf slime what the heck i didn't expect that i thought you would want a lollipop
slime oh i forgot god make the slain girl as close to strongy's but what just to upset me even more
you want to upset me reeflings how dare you can we get a methodic did body type got you covered
already and add that's exactly for azura's body type for the architect southern cow pork
chubby pig girl oh no i wouldn't put a pig on a big body type that's not nice
slain girl you can drown in i mean i guess uh it looks like azura is still winning so yeah
slain girl being thick to drown in her yeah a urethra slice if wait right i'll tell you what
if i ever develop a slain girl the first audio i'll make her a record is a slain girl claims
into your urethra and tickles your pickle from the inside out that'll be my deal you asked for
slain girl she's she's crawling inside upset slain mummy well slain mummy is i'm satisfied
stop the count i'm satisfied right what claw is the slain
and okay what color is the slime is the question
no deal promise slain girl digest you she has a deal that sounds very uncomfortable is there a
downside to stop uh you don't have to sell her anymore jokes on you i'm into that
have her climb into me and pilot my meat so i would be down for that i like the main control
thing you want a brown slime no okay so here we go uh done okay there's your slime girl right can we
move on teasing i'll actually put some effort okay so we've got we've got milf oh hold on the
well milf slime why wait i told it to make the text black oh it doesn't matter
okay first pick the color scheme oh wait hold on that's like gonna be in her hair right milf
slime one two and three we need to pick a color scheme green white a brown slime just sounds like
diarrhea jello okay that's kind of mildly true red would be a unique slime claw
base i'm a sucker for blue i mean she you yeah hex was originally supposed to be blue but kind of
messed up between what so like blue for one claw of the slime and then the accent color will be like
a neon pink i think this is the accent claw have like little hints of it in between maybe
maybe like green as well like just make her like really just off of rgb slightly and make her like
a jelly thing polka dot slime would be cute two tone white green or white purple
okay maybe not green then i don't think you guys are fuss for the green right how about accent
white and blue main and then accent is pink okay let's see what we can come up with now so
i can do right oh and just just for now imagine so that's the body okay now you can put clothes on
a slime girl it looks terrible i know it looks terrible but you can put clothes on a slime girl
see it oh no she's she's she's on hello sherbert's slime
paint bucket artis what can i say i really i do myself now i like when the slime girl
is dripping i and because you guys wanted the milk i wouldn't mind some sort of
like implications of dripping here oh that's awful that's like nothing like a drip holy crap
Oh my god, that's- how the frick do you make a drip? Like dripping from the belly button and stuff. How do you do that?
Why is this so much harder?
Oh my god.
Haven't you found respect for concept artists? I can't believe it.
All that took was one attempt at doing something and then I understand why it's not as- she got that drip rain jacket body
So white droplets. Oh, it probably should actually be white. Very oopsies. Let me just add a little white onto it real quick. Oh
little
Whiteness in there
I'm dripping from the belly button
You can't really drip from a toe. So we'll drip from that ankle
Is your drip? You just need to draw sweat honestly. Okay. Now you can draw an outfit
So sue is currently the most popular slime, and I will not be taking any aligunkies that she's not
If she's blue like if she's actually blue, I think I might have to give her what yellow jacket like actual rain jacket style
Oh god, she looks like a genie. You know that? Oh my god
I don't think this is working the way I wanted it to. She's like princess leah like add some red in there
And then you've just got princess leah going on
She's blue. How buddy? How would I you want a swimsuit?
I like that. Keep cooking a swimsuit milk
That I do not mind
Healy is what profile picture. Thank you for coming to member. I appreciate it membership streams start up next week
Not this week next week
There's going to be ton of membership streams bombed right at the end of this month
Do I make myself clear? Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Right. I want a swimsuit. How do you draw a swimsuit? Hold on
I'm going to look up women's wet and
Because I don't know what it looks like because I wear a very funny swimsuit that covers me up completely
Mm-hmm
Um, I guess it would honestly just what we'll go for like the classic like the it would be like up here
It oh my god, that's quite a high. It's a hard to be
Oh, sorry, I've got that freaking spot. Well, I her thing went sideways
And then
I
Can you do hold on a minute. Can you do a swimsuit that looks like this?
Whoa, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me cook. Let me cook. Let me cook. This is awful
Don't let me cook by the way, but can I do a swimsuit
That's held up by straps. I'm just drawing a zero then if it's held up by straps
gosh darn it
Azura get out of my head. Oh, I'm like the kitten
Come here. Okay, so it's like this
Let's get rid of that. He's just getting a bit confused and that's in the way
Uh, and then what uh, what was the slimes name be slime mix slime McGee?
I don't know
She can't have a naked model in each of the slime needs clothes jeweler the fake delete you
Uh, she has a skeleton. I don't know. Slimes are like osmosis. I feel like she'd accidentally pick stuff up though
So I wouldn't mind putting some jewelry on her. Fuck it. You can get like a wee anklet thing going on
This is just Azura. God damn. Why is it so hard right? What would be inside a slime?
What a slime would accidentally pick up juice. Whoa, where's my thing?
Right, let's let's put some juice
Slimes love juice. So we're going to give her a can of cola in her thigh. Okay. This is cola
There we go, so she actually got cola in her
Um
White button down dress through she be office. Maybe there is no she be. This is gen two. We've got hex
We've got milf slime that doesn't even have a name yet. I'm unironically ever just going to call her slime McGee right now
Slimey
Slime McGee
Here we go
Beautiful stunning gorgeous for her eyeball. You'll never guess what's going to be in her eyeball
So she's gonna have that and then her eyeball is going to be a droplet. Okay
But the actual
pupil hold on let me let me close this off so I can do the old copy and paste method
A chris diet
Diet cook, diet cook. Don't let strongy pick names again. Still I'm so sad that I'm not allowed to name after admit
The names up and picked her way better than anything I could have come up with. Oh, hey
Um, right drop
A little droplet like would be her pupil and it like wiggles around
And then we're gonna do that boom just like that
And then obviously we'll just add like a bit of weight to do the
Um, like highly saying that I anime eyes always have
So now we will draw on the slimes. Oh, you have lovely anime at big anime eyes gorgeous stunning, right do the half
Whoa
I made this oh, I actually made it bigger. Okay. Do the half face. It's like down here
Okay, do the eye do the eye do the eye do the eye and then she's like looking at you with her gliby eyes
Oh god, she's gonna be alien
She's got very big eyes
Very big anime eyes
Anime anime give them an anime
And then we do the accent color which is this
Pink which I've literally not put anywhere else on the design
I don't know who designed her but you've done a terrible job
Because you've not done any of that accent color. Okay
I'm like jewelry, but I'm like Azura has jewelry. I'm just recreating Azura
Pondela Buzum. No
Fondela slime are you slimy curls?
Jelsica
Like the silicone gel pot, you know someone said she has a pet fish in there her mascot could be swimming around inside her
Maybe she got like a little fishy in her tummy
And then she then whenever she cancels stream and she's like I've got a sore tummy is because there's a fish in her
Yeah
Come on. That's like so smart
There and then she I was so her her shtick is like she cancels streams and she go she go tummy hurt
Tummy hurt
Stream cancelled
Stream can't sit a little
Cuz fish
Yeah, there we go
Boom right there a little arrow pointing to the fish come on me
That's beautiful. Of course the first thing I see is my oh
Because everyone would shut the fuck up about a goddamn slime girl
So I give I give him so whenever someone was in the slime girl
I can be like there there she is looking all ugly and shittly designed in the corner
At least like hex had something going for her, but slimy slime magie. It just looks awful
Jella pronounced Jella. Why is it got a
Good in front of it then because that's a good. That's a good letter. Okay, you see good
Slime girls were it should be a baby shark. Oh should we give her a slime tail while we're at it might as well
Just just fucking farmer out the wazoo there
She's got a big slimy tail and she sucks you in with it and everything gets stuck to there
Can you make her more drippy and wet she's like a round wavetail
What if each item inside is related to the members of the
Wait, am I gonna do that? I am an idiot
But I'm a happy idiot. That's the main thing there
She's got a big ugly tail as well just to really emphasize. She's a slime right now. We need to deal with her freaking hair
Right slimes are always droplet shaped. So what she's got like droplet bangs
No, that's awful. Right. No bangs. You are getting big ugly forehead because I hate you so much
Right. No do what
Right, so the side bangs have to be a tear shape like that. That's that's unavoidable
Oh
Can she have
A droplet ahayio or whatever the it's not ahayio. That's the uh thing
Most of the deeper it comes in the shine of the drops looks more shiny
So you admit it dempa you two understand that I hate sleep
Just adding shine to the skin and the shadows will do a lot
If she has the soccer mom personality, you can call her ghillie
Cuz screaming jello huge drops on the side of her head
Like I
This is oh my god. Just give her a bowl cut. That's how much I hate her. Go away
I don't like you don't ever cook again. Right. What does she have though?
Would you have like a spout hair style? No
A fucking shower head look right and then what her hair would just be long and flowing. I think
There's no way it wouldn't be. Oh my god. This is she looks like jar jar bangs. No
This is even worse. How about this? Oh, right just just
Ah
This looks like jar jar fucking bangs misa slime girl misa gonna hug you
Ah, this is awful awful awful
At least hexa has something going for her like seriously look at hexa compared to slimy slime McGee. This is awful
Hair would be ocean frost
Yeah, it's not just coffee a cat a slime girl from monster misumi
I like
I got on dvd
Misa joining the via sucky. No
Right, that'll be our catchphrase and then it's over with I never have to think of a slime girl again
Was it me me?
Join
Did you say misa joiner?
V sucky
That's the catchphrase. Well, that's not catchphrase. I don't give a shit. I do not I couldn't give less of a shite
Hold on. This is a bit too close to the head of the next one
Oh
Her slime covers half of her face hiding the fact that she has a single eye swimming in her head
How does this happen? How do you create jar jar banks by accident? I don't know
Okay, so she's got cola in her thigh absolutely no detail
What's so ever going on other than a cola in the thigh a few droplets a tail that I don't it makes no sense
And for some reason when she's got fish in her stomach. So when she cancels streams
Her tummy hurts because of the fish
Another slime girl. No, you're done. And then she's fucking jar jar banks. Okay
Now that we've got that out of our system
We have
three body types remaining. We've got two lollipops and a regular schmigular joe
Why do you hate them so much? I don't hate them
I cannot
I cannot in good consciousness give a slime girl
to someone if we were to expand the team at velour
because
It's such
It's the gimmick is funny for five seconds and then no one's laughing
Give her to me all yours all yours, baby take jar jar banks
Slime slime McGee me so join a visa key. Shawnee hate manifested and the only creature she hates enough to depict that
Shawnee aren't we missing one? There's not there is no totally not mercy present
We need six girls for Jen. No, no, we just need the five because
So we've got two lollipops a regular to go so what do you need a butterfly girl
A butterfly girl
I'm indifferent to slimes and v-tubers
The only thing if an indie become slime on their own another and need to cast someone in another role jar jar gips
Oh, that's actually such a good name
jar jar
get
There's a big niche for it, but it's very specific. I just think they're cute by gay
I say here is my most goofy suggestion that I could think of
Claudia scientists that perform ethically questionable research on chat involving electrical devices
lowly white slash green slash
Wait in green
Oh, you didn't see what kind of green be you said I'm mad scientist. So I kind of feel like neon
green
what's
Kuderi, I think I know what kuderi is
But I'm just gonna look up just in case look we're in the information age
You're allowed to look up a Japanese time for a character appears to not have emotions
Oh, she's gonna have very creepy eyes if that's the case
Wait, what was it? I think I'll thank you math for the kuderi scientists
A science I'm with the science team
Okay, let's do her eye
if she's a scientist
Oh god, what's that? Oh god science symbols. I don't want the radiation one. I want like the poison one
Mmm, I'm looking online and we could do a proton technically
We could do DNA if she what can if you're saying she does unethical testing
I it's giving DNA and if you didn't know deoxyribonucleic acid
Based off the blue ghost firefly which is smaller than a grain of rice
I'll show you my grain of rice. What does that mean?
You didn't give me any iPhone. I would give the DNA sequence
Um
We could what would her accent color be red?
Like minish style
I turned myself into an animated tube a girl morty
No, don't don't
Miss morgan four armed firefly lollipop based off of the blue ghost firefly, which is small
A firefly like a red angry thing
I mean, we don't really have red
Maybe possibly plausible. Thank you for
Eating it Raven I turn myself into an anime girl. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, no, no, no, right accent color
Green and purple
Question mark green and purple and white
Yeah, yeah
Big lab coat should we do like when the arms go over I like when that when it's a lollipop and the arms like completely go over
I've not
Hmm might hold on hold on if purple is going to be the other color. We're going to connect the
DNA via the lines like that now it would probably be a bit smaller in her eyeball, but I mean, we've got it
We've got it right. Okay
Now ignoring hexa right there. Um
Lab coat that's too big
She's 19 bus 10 PhDs because she's so smart honestly, she was setting calculus at nine. What were you doing at nine years old?
That's right playing Beyblades
That's right. Green purple white familiar colors game
Strangling
I'm not purple if you were asking the new purple
Green and purple. Yes. Okay. Uh a lab coat
Oh
How the heck is it? Yeah, okay, and it's too big for her
So she'd have like sleeves that come all the way out like
Scientists oh wait, why didn't Brian you didn't read that out. How the frick do you draw a lab coat? Oh my god
I don't uh, so do you know that thing where you can imagine stuff in your head? I can't see stuff in my head
I have to like look at stuff. Thank you lorda storms for the extended membership
Scientist girl must glow like neon from experimenting on herself. She's actually a government
well
Right, so a lab coat can be open. I am tempted to do an open lab coat
and
Um, she's like really inappropriate in her conduct
I think I quite like that
So that's what you're getting
and then
She doesn't wear anything in this area, but she will wear like purple panty loons
Okay, let's let's extend that there and then we'll just go up the body
and then
You will copy this say yeah, that's right. We're getting there. Yeah, that's right. Mm-hmm. You're gonna do a bit of
Right and then we're gonna erase all of this because I visually can't see it unless like this is gone
Okay, there we go. I can start I'm starting to see a little bit
Just a wee bit though
There's gonna be there's gonna have to be a lot of details on our lab coat for it to kind of
form a
Some sort of coherent design. Gonna be honest. It's not looking good already
But that's not gonna stop us when is when is being shit at anything ever stopped us reeflings. Hey, come on
Okay, there we have
something
But why are hips so big? You know what? It's fine. It's fine. Okay. And then first things first. She doesn't wear anything on
This area so we need to remove this
Like so
Is she petan? I think she's petan
I know emi's petan and I'm using emi's base, but like come on
Okay, there we go
Okay, we've got the lab coat sorted
She's awesome already
And then she wears purple
Tongs
I'm just kind of
Wait, is there a sim? Wait, hold on. Let me look at the symbols of science again. I could maybe do a symbol
Oh
I've just got an idea. How about she wears something like this, right? Okay
but secretly
This is like
It goes to the side like that and it secretly like goes all the way up here like in some crazy kind of scheme design
I don't know if I'm making any sense and then it has the um
It has the neon green
And this time the scent we need to really zoom in for this one. Gotta get it accurate or else there's no point in doing it all
It's the atomic symbol like the radiation one. It's like the circle in the middle as well
Ah, yes, she has a triangle. Why yes, of course
And then obviously she has a pocket and then and and you know like instead of putting pens in it
She has like, I don't know a radioactive test tube that is literally glowing on her damn chest
because uh, you know
What when did a bit of radiation ever stop her? Let's be honest
A one-piece micro sling bikini the radio is say exactly she remember at the home. Yeah
Because and then like the string perfectly covers up her
You know
That's the biohazard. Okay. Well, she's got a biohazard. She's see then
um
Because she's a scientist she unironically wears like the steel tap steel toe cap to boots
So she wears like the nice big boots
that are uh approved. Um
I don't how do how do you draw steel?
What steel?
Steel toe capped boots. Jeez go to sleep already. My goodness
like the these ones
Oh my god, it looks like roman sandals, but it's because I don't know how to just draw them
But like she wears like big chunky boots. Okay
And she's got a little lab coat. She's got a little radioactive thing going on. I'm here for it. Honestly, uh
But
Because she's an inappropriate scientist
She has like decorations and stickers and stuff on her outfit that really shouldn't be on it
But that's pretty much it
Uh biohazard icon over the yeast infections
Uh, right your eyeballs. Let's draw your dna sequence eyeballs
Okay, wait, that's a bit too high up
Okay, now she is freaky and has like no emotions. So she's got like extra weirdness going on
So it's green
And then purple dna to connect green
The oxyl deoxyribonucleic acid
Oh well
And then the purple I got purple. Nope that is purple
I thought that
I thought I caught that and then it's like goes over like this like in the dna sequence
I do love my dna. It's a double helix, which is extra cool
It means you can store even more genetic information on it. It's really cool. I mean I think that's an end right for her hair
I
Would love for her fringe to be pinned back
The question is what color should her hair be? Should it be black?
I don't think it should be purple
I think it actually should be black with like an accent of purple
So I actually want her fringe to be pinned back
So I don't know how you draw that though, but basically oh god
No, not the freaking baby like like it's pinned back
Because she needs to keep her hair out of her face, but she you know what I mean, right?
Right, you know, I mean like her thing and her little fringe is back
um
And then because she's in science she has to like have her hair in like little adorable bunches at the side
Um because you need to tie your hair back or it'll explode
Oh my god, what does it look like? Oh, she looks awful
Oh
Green with purple highlights
But yeah, she got like a little fringe back. I don't know how to draw it anime style, but her fringe is back. Okay
And then she's got purple highlights in her hair not green purple
Oh wait the freaking everyone has like some sort of highlight in her hair
Or should we pardon me? Sorry. Should we do block color?
Once
Say
No, well because her eyes are mixed her hair should actually be mixed. You know that
If I think because it would it would like a
Um
Complement her wee eyes more. Oh wait. No, she's supposed to be emotionless
There she's so emotionless and she's tired because you know
No
Okay, I think we did it
She should have braces like a nerd. Okay, let's add the braces. Let's see. Let's get a little teeth shot from our little nerd
And just to really show the acts the colors like constantly switching back and forth
This one then this one then this one then this one then this one
And then we're going to yank this color right here
And then do this this this this and this is her teeth
And the braces just connect to one another like that
Yeah, that's how braces work right surely. I wouldn't know I'm brish
Okay, let me cook a lollipop armadillo girl who maybe has jewels on her armor
A contortionist girl since they can roll into balls
Gray as a primary color with perhaps orange and red
Loose clothes for aerodynamics a little shy, but not while performing
I'm not sure. Thank you for the tip tiny tiny
I've seen armadillo. I don't know
Or a madillo and madillo and madillo. Let me just give her a neck again. Hold on a minute
It's timmy from south pot. No, right we need to give her a name
What's her name going to be?
She does science, but it's unethical
So call her unni. Oh, and she's we as well. So we'd call her unni
because you know
she got the
For no particular reason at all her name tag is going to be right here
She's called unni because she's unethical
Oh, ne ne e like that unni and then
Some sort of science name
Uh another word for science, please internet. What do you see synonyms for science?
yep
art discipline education information learning skill system technique branch
Erudition lore
unni lore
Unni ology unni ology. Yeah
ology is the study of whatever the subject that comes before it. So like bi ology is the study of life
Chem ology. I'm just kidding. But that that's actually true. That's actually true what I said there, but chem ology doesn't work
So unni ology welcome in unni ology. I actually am not that mad at the design. I think that's really funny
You know, I'm sure someone else could cook a lot better with that, but yeah, come on unni ology
Her name is use lingo. Ah, yes. It means cousin unni one studied dark magic other studied medicine
She specializes in sista
She's a harm assist. Oh my god. Yes
The harm is oh my voice cracked there. I got so excited. He or me
sit it
harm assist
Ta-da, and she got her eyes. She's got a color scheme. We've got a new song called theme
Okay, we have a regular schmagular and a little adorable
Baborable. Let me read chat. She's really cute. Give her to me. Yike my design now says dempo
We'll all act surprised when dempo's new model comes out
unni ology and her assistant Mike honey
I loved aces a little short when she said that she's like, I'm not very smart and in two seconds later
Thank you for the don on my honey
like I say
A bioluminescent yearly fish
another animal
Hydrate you
Bang I'll open up my bowl of water. Jeez. You're so stinky
Mmm
So we've got jar jar banks. We've got unni ology and we've got hex and then no surname
I want to birth cute girl
She may be addicted to sweets, but her experience on her subjects with coke and other high sugar products
Oh my god, is she like Freud and she's on the
Okay, okay. She's on she's on that Freud arc. Okay. She on the the what's it bigger sugar
She's got she just really wants results. Okay. She wants she's obsessed with hypothesis hypothesis
Hypothesis
She like loves coming up with them
She wants all the hypothesis and she wants to prove them there and then when they come into her jar jar banks
Yeah
Mesa join and be sucky
This will just be dempa's first feature agent for her agency
Name her hex and bacon. Are you squiddin me right now? Oh, honestly, I'll take it
Idea cute lollipop goblin girl with big boobah that is a hunter and the thing she is hunting for is someone to make with
Also, she needs to have large ears sharp teeth and thick thighs
Also for personality. She would be very mischievous
An orc a tribal orc that wants you. Okay. Let's let's check out the color palette
Color palette first, you know the drill. Oh wait, hold on. I need it. I need it big, right? Okay. Lollipop skinny Maliki
Thank you gaming kitsune for the suggestion
We're gonna do we're gonna have to change the skin right off the bat boom boom
And the ears start coming and they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming and I'm coming
And I'm coming and I can't stop coming. I'm addicted. Please. Please upload another audio, please
Okay. Um, no, I still needs to be a lighter. Oh my god. I can't believe I'm being
Come on. There we go. She's like, uh, the reason she's so tiny is because
Because she's tiny, okay
If the girls were born to pander to you, what would she be? Um, I already picked what I wanted for gen two
I did not get what I wanted for gen two
um
Back and discuss it more at a later date right now
What I what I can't see my discoveries. Okay. Let's join her neck up. Okay, so
So lollipop goblino with big boobs
Okay
Oh that one was now. Don't worry. It's perfectly natural if one's bigger than the other but maybe not to that degree
Okay, it's kind of like oh why oh my god
I'm a real artist now because all I'm doing is controls Ian
Okay, but what
What should we uh, you know what I like I like when the design comes over like this
Can I put her in rags? Oh my god, please can I put her in rags? I love rags
How do you draw rags?
I didn't think I would get this far. Hold on a minute
I want to know what's true anyone soon soon. No one would be revealed
uh
I'll show I'll show what I asked for and I'll show what I got basically what is going on in here
We're putting boobs on a lollipop
And I suck at it
But we're got we've got hicks and bacon. We've got uneology, which actually really like the idea of
unironically getting her developed
Uh, we've got jar jar binks the milk milk slime. Um, and then we're currently working on
A little tiny orc that loves to our word
There's no two ways about it. Did you give her a name? She likes to hunt. Okay, so she's into prey
Okay, she's into the prey. Was it prey play? Is that what you guys taught me like literally yesterday?
She's into prey play. Okay, not the amen. Okay, not the hot amen
That's supposed to be two hands together is not working
Pitcher plant lollipop that attracts pdf files and eats them
Oh
Gen two idea a hypnotic cuttlefish, but she loves slime girls. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No no miss. I see how it is. I see how it is
Uh, grembo. Thank you for the tip rags that barely cover
Okay, I like that hold on. I guess I do like a sideways thing so it covers like this
But then like that bit skin
And it's all kind of like being pulled
Uh, no, I do like a picture plant idea. It's not the worst
But uh, maybe the attraction on is a bit of a oh, not sure we can really do that one chief
Uh, thank you for the suggestion on the left. Right. So this this is how it works, right? Surely this is how it works, right?
So in order to
What are you drawing? I don't know
I would have to go like that. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
And then what I don't know. Well, just keep trying. Okay
Then that would have to be your skin
So then you need to you need a smaller line to symbolize that it's skin here. Oh
Sorry, I'm having to like talk myself through this process. Oh god, right
So if it's a single line, it shows that it's like a wee bit of skin, right? Okay. Yeah, that's fine
And then in order to compliment the green
Yes, we're actually going to do a paler brown
For the rags that should do it venus venus more like a penis fly trap
All right. Well, you as violers don't fucking V say so so
Shit, what do you want?
God, you guys are hard to impress even when I entertain you with a slain girl. It's still not enough for you. Is it?
Shopping baby, okay
This is how it works truly, right? So this is clearly rags, right?
Clearly and then
God, I like how it extends over her freaking elbow. That's how big it is
And we'll do we'll leave in the under boob as well. That's a loop
Okay, and then you just kind of draw like that
How does that look from afar? Whoa, wait that actually looks kind of good
Am I I'm I just am I being delusional or does that actually look kind of good? I think I'm being delusional
I think I need a good bed
I can't tell if I'm being delusional or if that kind of looks like a bit thingy
Uh, strongy slain girls and goblins are top tier. Yeah, I'm like, is this delusion or is this actually kind of good? I don't know
That's probably just pure delusion. Right. Let's first get rid of these
Why?
Right first, it's a lot easier to just do this first instead of the backwards way that I just did it, but yeah
The boobs are a bit how dare you
How dare you this isn't you're watching
Uh top tier rated vtubers be be born
Birth from my loins. I'm just down it. Okay. So first thing you do this
What strongy? That's just your design. Yeah. Yeah, I know. I know just give me a second to freaking catch up
If she's wearing rags, okay
It has to be like really sporadic because she's like tried her best to cover up
But she's not the smartest. Okay, so she's just kind of got things that are like pulling against her skin
in order to do this
um
And
Oh, you know what fuck it. Why not?
We'll do have like a random knot in the middle because she had to like knot it in order to like hold them together
Because because that's how it works. Okay. She's trying her best. Be nice to her
You've not even given her a name yet
Right, that's it reeflings name that are word goblin right now
Jumps on your
technical uh
I don't know what her name would be jumps a lot jumps
Jumps a cop jump
Okay, was it hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me get up. Let me get up
jump
pisa
jumps uh
cox
There that's her name jumps a cox
See this is why I should name because she would never get that you'd never get that jumps a cox. Okay
She's a noblin. Oh, yeah, you like that. We're gonna call her a noblin because she's a wee little
Little bit lit in noblin there. Her nickname is noblin and her her her full legal name is jumps a cox
Nob goblin literally
Goblin my noblin
Right stop. I'm getting excited. I'm getting excited. Calm down. Calm down. Okay. There boom
Okay, so her rags are like tied up like that. She's tried her best
But she doesn't really care at the end of the day right
She would have dark markings to like compliment
Her thingy and they start lighting up them. We're excited she gets
And like all her symbols are like off like I don't know fertility or stuff. I don't know how this works. She'll have like loads of symbols
Maybe it's just be her veins. Honestly. It's probably just like her veins and stuff
So the more you see like her heart and stuff that's the more wait hearts on the left side a little bit
If that her left then it's the heart should kind of be on the side a bit more
There we go. That's the heart beautiful stunning gorgeous. Um
Can you like tribal tattoos? I don't I mean I get I just
And they just show up a bit more
Oh my tiny squid mirror
Get out of the kitchen. You might
No, what's wrong with the design
Oh garden rams. He says get out of the kitchen. What do you mean? You don't like my tribal design. Come on
You know how to draw tight. I don't even know what tribal freaking tattoos look like
There and she has like markings all over and got like one big one on her leg
And then this is the conception
Hey
Um, and then we've got uh the wiggly
The wiggly meets the egg
This is the ovum
That's the ovum over
And that's the swimmer
And she's all about the uh, oh that's
I
I'm supposed to have to you know, just put one up there in the shop in there
She's keltic war paint. She's war paint on her face. Okay. Okay. I'll give her war paint
She's always ready to raid, you know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. She's like a war thing and she's like, um, always
Oh, shit. I'm covering this up. I'm always ready
to
And then in in big bold
That's her that's her little her mole
I'm always ready to ride
Uh pray play. Yes. Yes. Yes jumps on you
She's really into breeding. She has to have a womb tattoo. Right. Okay fine. Ah little laughs
How does one
So in the oh, that's very large actually in the middle of her tattoo is the egg that you have to go for. Okay
um, but it's not going to be a love heart because
It's going to be an upside down love heart because it's not being conceived from love. It's been conceived from the
Alternative so that's these are clearly her little egg holders. They're her ovaries
um
and then she's got like a little pipe going on
and then
Just a few like little things that they should be creating vtuber freaking
Hmm
Uh, how you call them again, we'll do the little circle inside. That's the ovum. That's the egg waiting to be fertilized
Got all of science. It's so cool. Honestly. I mean, I think it's cool
Okay, there she's got a little womb tattoo as well
And then she's got like little swirls down here just because she can
Wait a minute. Mercy did swirls on my leg. I'm copying mercy. Uh
I'm really bad for that. My brain's just like, um, you've seen this once before so do it again. I was like, no
It's a little random markings. Why not? Oh, maybe she has scars
Oh my god, she would have like scars because people would try and fight her off
But she always wins in that end anyway, so there's no point in fighting her. Hold on
She has like a teeth mark here
Yeah, there's like no point in fighting her like good luck. I honestly look like a smiley face
The the head and uh, thank you for becoming a member. I appreciate the support and she got like a big scar
That used to be an open cut up here, but it's not anymore
and then
uh, maybe a shoulder bite like uh coffin of andy and lele style
Maybe on her finger because like someone like she went for someone and they weren't having it
But she managed to like not hurt herself
anywhere
Scars or tally marks does she have colored nails?
Sure
Yeah
Okay, we need to give her her eyeballs. Oh my god, how do you translate her?
Design into an eyeball
Um
She would have teeth she would have like orc. Oh, sorry. She would have orc teeth, right? Surely surely she would have orc teeth
So she would have like the big teeth that come out here. I love them and orcs have the underbite teeth
And then she like smiley. She's all happy
Okay, open your eyes, please so we can take a look at your eyeballs
Come
Okay, so what would your eyeballs actually be did I draw your eyeballs? No, I didn't
Yeah, let's draw it up here
Come. Oh, no, your hair is gonna be in the way
Okay, one big eyeball
What would your design
be
I feel like we've got what is an accent color to green and like tan
Brown, I mean she could have brown eyes
And maybe I put wee sandals on her so she can run after you and her wee flip flops
So as you're trying to run away from her all you hear is like
Over server freaking sandals honestly, that's hilarious. Like you can't get away. It doesn't matter how far
She's literally the like you can't it doesn't matter how far you run. She's like right behind you
Okay, she's gonna wear sandals. So it's got a little bit in between the tool here
How do sandals look when you're wearing them?
Ah, yes, I remember. Oh my gosh. I'm like a five-eyed
There so like and just just like behind you
Doesn't matter how far you run. She's she's right behind you
Little flip-flops little flip-flop gang flip
flop
Approaching sounds apperate. Oh arching
sounds
Mm-hmm
There we go flip-flop approaching sounds
Uh, I think she would actually maybe have brown eyes
Do we give her the old hex method where it's like brown in the middle and then tan on the outside
And then a darker brown
For the actual people what would the symbol be it has to be has to be an egg in an ovum
Thank you mama for the big asset lollipop. It's glorious
Big asset lollipop. Oh the thing
So this I'm wondering if we could secretly draw a little swimmer and her pupil
I think we could which is a little like from afar though
A bit shit, but honestly
Honestly, you went up high lolly. Is that what you want? Oh, no lollipop lollipop lollipop
What did you do
I can't remember do you like
Okay, and then we're gonna draw
The egg in the ovum not the best pupils, but you know why we've done it
She looks like a freaking alien at this point. Okay
It's that's the egg and the little one thing going on and the we spare me wearing me
Oh, this is awful. This is cursed
But vealer already has an r-word in goblin her name is joining as terrible
Refling journal supposed to say that I like right here
We are gonna have lovely luscious wavy brown hair like I'm talking hair down to the floor
I love when hair goes down to the floor
So we've got luscious bang. So let's do the bang
And then she has like this gorgeous
hair that
Oh, maybe it should like rest on the bosom a little bit on her fondle of bosoms
But then it keeps oh, no, that doesn't work
Well, the back of the hair can definitely go like all the way of the back. That's fine with me
Maybe it just comes to us like uh in the middle
Like predator style like it just all comes down
Leave her bald don't say such things we put so much love into her
Okay, we definitely need to deal with her mouth though. I don't I don't want to be rude
But your mouth is starting to worry me a little bit
Okay, and then we'll just kind of have a little accent pieces here
And then we can remove this part because this is where it looks really weird
And then can we
Maybe do this close enough. Uh, right. Let's try that again. We'll see what is the
Impeding ours
Uh color wise
What is
Ah, this bit here we go. I got it. Are you squid me right now?
Something every girl has a straight bangs. I sense some of my house leave my straight bangs out of this
I'll love my straight bangs. Okay. Hmm. Oh wait. Do they actually all have straight bangs? No
frickin
uneology
Hazard things pinned back get wreck
Anonymous, how do you say such things to me anonymous? I'm gonna fart on your eyelashes
Stony you gave her hair, but you just let it flow down. Are you confirming that you're no
I I don't I don't it's not me. I promise. I'm designing something here. It's not me
It's me
Me
Why did you space out that here? Let's just close all the gap. Don't mind us close gap. Boom. No, let's try again
What is open here?
This
Is it that be honest? Was it that? Is that the reason why it's not closed? Boom. Are you?
Am I being squitted on I'm being squitted on by ms pain. Are you what are you doing ms pain everything else is blocked off
I can see everything else is blocked off
Come on. Oh, there is sorry. That was really obvious
There we go, she's got two different. Yeah. Yeah, fuck it right here. How's a gradient? Why not get darker at the bottom?
He he he I guide it. Okay, and then
for the mouse let's maybe relax a bit on it and
We will make it a slightly less intimidating
Uh, maybe just one odd tooth. Why not?
And then she's all smiley and sweet, but it's because she's secretly about to do something very bad
Uh, and she's all she's like a little sweetheart and you're like, oh this orc
I don't know why orcs have such a bad reputation. Seriously. Why do people hate them so much?
And then little do you know what's about to come next?
Oh, yeah, we did it. We did the design. So now
We have one more design and then we're done. So
Hmm what we think and not gonna let her go feral
Oh, they have long ears. How could I forget? She needs her long side late ears. Hold on. Hold on. Let me add the ears real quick
And this is jumps on. Yeah
Oh
Why am I born like this? Okay. She has adorable little ears that come out from this side
Like this like these kind of ears
Ta-da, all done
You what orc or goblin? I don't know one or the other. Are you squid me? Noblin if you if you prefer
Red black gold color scheme discord kitten girl. Red black and gold. Why not?
We don't have a red
We have avoided red for some reason
Right red black and gold black and gold wasn't that song when a fish swims out of the ocean
And the legs they start as walking
Oh
Red black and gold discord kitten
Ray
We've just made belgium. So she's belgium for one 10 out of 10 would let the gobby. Oh my god, her nickname would so be gobby
Gobby
Oh, yeah
I think what is she singing you know how it's like when the fish swim out in the ocean
And legs they started when the fish swam out of the ocean
What is you what does google say?
Oh, it's called the song is called black and gold. Yeah, no wonder. Okay. Are you ready for the lyrics?
I'm gonna sing it because I don't want to copyright
Oh, wait, hold on. I need to mute the background music just to really not confuse you
When if the fish swam out of the ocean and grew legs and they started walking
And the apes climbed down from the trees and grew a tail and they started talking
And the stars fell out of the sky
And the tears rolled into the ocean
And now i'm looking for a reason why you even set my world in emotion
Ka-mmm
Because if you're not really here, I don't remember this though. Where's the black and gold part? Here we go
I want to be next to you
black and gold
That's it
But there was a song it goes like that just tape it and i'm gonna no copyright
I'm gonna have the most delirious sleep of my life. I'm gonna wake up tomorrow not remember. I did any of this
Because I haven't slept in like how long?
quite well
I'm gonna have any recollection that I designed any of these so it'll be a nice surprise to wake up to
Do you have a backstory idea? Wait, what was it? I don't even remember what the question was
Discord kitten someone said discord kitten. Okay, right this this
P Y R D K
Y K I N
There we go. Spell it like that just i'm feeling feeling quirky
So i'm gonna spell it like that no stroney the goblin is singing this no matter how fast no matter how far you can always hear
The squeaking behind the lollipop goblin is coming to town
lollipop
goblin
Are you squiddling me around?
I've left goblin a gob on my knob with all without permission
Gob on my knob schlob on my cob
Norn on the cob and she give me hay right on the bay
Check in with me and do your job right you what are you you're a discord kitten?
Obviously you need the headset or else it's not complete. How can you be the stereotype and you need braces?
Get braces right automatically. She's disqualified from being british. So unfortunately it is what it is
We will give her red and gold braces because we can't
Oh
That's what
Yeah, that's right. That's right. Get braces get braced on get braced on i'm getting braced getting braced. That's right
And then she's got a big old she's got a big old smile
Because she likes to show off. She's got braces. She's so mature for her age
Why am I grooming her? She's not even real
There just just smile and there i'm just gonna put erratic dots in your teeth. Okay
It looks like you've got like red chili peppers stuck or something
okay
Yo, is that the flag of belgium unironically though, but how will she?
with braces
Because she can right if she's a discord kitten. What eyeball are we giving you?
Come on. Let's get that pupil design. Let's milk that pupil design for everything move go
Right if you're a discord kitten
What's the discord symbol look like? Hold on let me look it up. What does discord symbol look like?
Image
Okay, the discord symbol right so first do a circle because we need it to be in the circle
Okay, the circle is gonna wear the headset but in say the circle is the discord
Who goes there?
Big black cat ears and tail actual cat girl not just headphones gimmick make her very desperate for love and attention
But a real gamer girl veteran
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. There we go. So that's her pupil
uh
I would have to be red though
Right, you want a real neko real neko. So let's get rid of this
Mmm, and you want a real tail. I can definitely do that. Let's give her black
um
Thingy so she's got a lovely tail
No, that looks like a dinosaur or something
No, don't get skinny
Oh, it's your boy
Yeah, we go she's got a little tail and has a little Brenda then she's so happy to see you
Dollar signs from all the sugar daddies cat girls speaking of a cat girl. You'll never guess what Fu is
Fu is sometimes gets referred to as not a neko
This is not fun for Fu
But she is a nekodese
What color though red red eye seems like really intense, but
I think it's gonna have to be
Unless we do like something really weird like that. That's the weirdest pupils. I think we're drawing. It looks like a pig's nose
I understand now why you said pig
I didn't understand. She's gonna need a you blue shirt, honestly
I'm gonna have to redesign that pupil a little bit or it's just gonna have to be like one shade of red
Well, not one shade like I'll make it later
Oh
That's even more like a pig. Who's thought right? How have I done a 3d pig? That's honestly such a good like pig
Right, it's not working
The pupil is just gonna have to have neko ears. There's no other way about it
The pupil is having neko ears. Did I make myself clear?
Okay, so pupil
Neko ears. Oh, this looks even worse
Oh brother, it's probably the best I've got
It's not very good up next the pig girl. No, no pig. Go right. Okay. She's got a tail
Next we need to do her hair
um
If she's a neat do we cover up her feet like her eyes
Oh
She looks like
Or something like one of the characters from there
Oh, right. I need to get rid of the teeth. I'm so sorry. They're completely throwing me off
They need to go. You got to go buddy. What do you mean? You have to go
I can't handle you
Wow
Right you do you you you you
And then draw a circle
Circle and then draw the cat ears and then and so that's just it looks like a freaking bunny rabbit head. Do you know that?
Only once I discovered I think sometimes her love for stylistic pupils make cause issues
Yeah, and what are you gonna do about it? And she's like, uh, she's like, uh, wait, how do you draw a hegeo face?
I hate you
Okay, and she's got her mouth open and it's like her tongue is it? What the fuck? How do you know this?
Someone stick their tongue out right now so I can use it as a reference
Oh, this is awful
Why is a hegeo so hard to draw? Who did this?
Why is it sideways? Right straightforward tongue, please. Thank you. And then
What why hello? Why is it so hard to draw? I literally have a reference right in front of me
right
First stick the tongue out
Okay
I'm literally right that's supposed to be the tongue wait. I've not done the mouth yet
And then the mouth is like a dark opening above it. Okay
Do that
And then color in the tongue. Okay there now you can tell that I'm trying to go for it
Jeez that was like way harder than it had to be
Okay, we did it we've done the face out of all the faces. There's a
Okay, go away jar jar slime
We've had enough of your shenanigans right here next a discord kitten always has long hair. Okay
But because she's doing a hegeo her little ears would be down so first
Long hair would we do like
Something I feel like she has to have something
I mean we'll put a bow in her hair just to make her slightly different. What's that bangs again?
Absolutely. No, let's give her a side swoop. Why not? A little emo cat thing going on
Wow
Okay, there we go
And then we'll put a little bow in her hair right here
A little jingle bell because you know how cats like those little bell things always get sold to them
My tongue is ready for you strongy. Thank you. I will draw it right now briefly
Your sacrifice will not be forgotten
Uh her hair is not going to be her hair is going to be long, but it's not going to be that long
And it's actually going to be a blunt cut
um
Because we don't want it to be
Not a blunt cut. Yep. Okay. I mean that's explanation enough and all honestly
You don't really have to go further than that and then we do a little hair thing here to mesh it a bit better
And then we introduce her ears which are pressed
Our ears up here and a cat. Yeah, okay
If the ears are up there the ears like bunch out like up here
And they're kind of like downwards because she's doing a hegeo. So it's supposed to be like
You know, I mean like this ear is getting completely hidden by this accessory
Who put the accessory right there? I don't know. It wasn't me, but someone did put it there and they should be embarrassed
If she's a big weeb maybe mess up the hair
Like this
There she's a still got a blunt cut, but it's only blunt because
She just doesn't go get it cut at all and doesn't maintain it whatsoever
Okay, and then if we copy that and we can paste it on the neck and we can do that
Well, maybe let's not color in her eyeballs. That would look rather odd. I oh are you squiddin me right now?
By the pope identify yourself
Suggestions tongue piercing bondage restraint on her tail that matches her choker on her neck
Short nails painted gold or black side swept short black hair
Gold jewelry to compliment her black slash red lounge wear outfit. Give her a giant fish plushie
Fish plushie. Fish plushie
Thank you for the
tip
Again Raven. Thank you
I I'm gonna be honest. My brain's starting to shut down. I'm I am now working against the clock before my brain stops talking
Um, uh, we are under the clock. I repeat rooflings. We are under the motherfucker clock
I don't want to fall asleep, but I think I might fall asleep, but I don't want to fall asleep on stream
That's not a nice
Black please. Thank you. She's got black ears
Don't fall asleep. Don't fall asleep. Don't fall asleep. Don't fall asleep. Just give her black ears because she's a nickel
And she's from belgium and and her catchphrase is
I can't remember how to spell dutch
I've completely forgotten how to spell in dutch
But she's fucking belgium
Um, I'm trying. I'm trying. Oh my god. We're against the clock. Okay
We need a light pink for the inner colors of her ear holes because we don't want her to not have light pink because
That's like humanizing her
You and I need to I'm trying to sleep somewhere. Congrats on 12k. I'm not at 12k. I just hit 11k. I know that for a fact
I'm not at 12k. Okay. Her hair is going to be a light brown
Can I do it? No. Okay. Well, I tried. Uh, let's try that again
Let's close off the gaps so we can get a nice light brown going on close
Closing the gaps closing the gaps
Looking for gaps looking for gaps. We're gonna do a light brown
I yet
Okay, there we go. There we go. There we go. We're getting there. We're getting there. We're getting there
Okay, okay. Let's let's put her together put her together put her together right
She has a tail. The tail is black
Um
But on the end of the tail she has the same bail. Oh, that looks like a pokemon. What's that pokemon's name?
It's not chingling. It's the other one
Oh, there's a pokemon that looks like it's that and it's not got that name
But it looks like what i've just drawn. I think i'm drawing pokemon from memory. I'm so sorry
Actually, I should do an msp drawn pokemon from memory. That would be insane. That's right
And then the elastic band
It would technically be black, but i'm gonna have to use red because I don't have anything else
And then the choker has the exact same
Like vibe
What's the pokemon chain chero? I think it's chain chero
There we go
I mean, yeah, like technically that band would be black and then this would be black. How do you symbolize it?
I guess gray symbolize it. We're gray
um
For the actual outfit
Body restraints on her tail that match her choker short nails
That are gold. I can do that
Boop boop
Um
Jewelry, I don't know cats like shiny things. No cats aren't man. Give her a giant fish
She likes she's got a little fish plushie. I know you said giant
But I actually like the idea that she's always got a fish stuffy on her because she's scared to go alone
Because her lore is that she was abandoned
And then she always wants a fishy to hold close because fishy were her only companions. No, she's not vegetarian
Just really gotta get in that real quick. No, she's not vegetarian. What would you wear though?
If you're a discord kitten you wear like next to nothing
I feel like you'd be in a spaghetti strap like crop top thing going on
Or maybe it would be like super stylized and she's got like
Bulging out the side, but she wouldn't have anything shown. You know, I mean
But I'd be like how does that shirt even work? Oh, I mean, I guess it would work if it went around the side like that
So technically this is her skin
Hold on. Let me zoom in. Let me enolize that's right. Hold on
If I want to pull off what I want to pull off first. I must color it all in
Okay, first color it in
color color color color color color
And then we redraw it with a thin black line. That's how art works. Okay, it just works
Not now Todd Howard. I need to go to bed
But it just works. No, Todd Howard. Stop it. Please change. Okay, so this is technically
You know what right
And then the actual shirt
Oh god, I forgot what the Belgian flag looks like. Hold on. It'll bell gian flag. Oh god, I cannot spell all
I'm falling asleep on stream and I don't want to please brain. Give me like give me five more minutes
Just give me one more chance
Thank you, that is my rendition of that one Japanese song that I have absolutely no idea what it's about
It just goes nowhere. The song has an English line and it just goes
Just give me one more chance
You know what song I'm on a bit, right?
You know what song I'm on a bit?
Surely surely copium
Okay, does that make sense what we're looking at here if I zoom out does it make more sense?
Yeah, yeah, it makes sense. Okay next shorts
No shorts, uh, all right you you
Can't put window or you want a window
I don't do that do skin color
And then draw
The shape
Go Belgium forever
Why else do I know about Belgium? Oh, that's her catchphrase
She wants she wants mayonnaise
Belgians and she wants your mail. Okay, because Belgians put mail on fries or chips
Or deep-fried potato. I don't know what you want to call it
But that's what they do and but the mail is her version of ink
Wait, is she Belgian? Yeah, we made her Belgian as fuck
She's a whole hat with the all you know
And she wants to watch new kids turbo with you. She's like so out the wazoo
New kids turbo
New kids
Turbo
Featuring
DJ Paul DJ Paul DJ Paul
That's such a specific reference like one person's gonna get on chat and they're gonna be absolutely stunned a random Scottish last kinds about it
You're welcome
What pride flag is that that's hilarious?
That's okay
Come on brain
Like you literally have like like two more minutes you have to do this for
You're fine. The design is there. Just get it out. Just get it out
Just get it out
Come on
Come on. The design is there. You know what to do
You know what to do brain. You know what to do with a
bird
wiggle wiggle wiggle
P. O. V. I am a pigeon that wants to meet with you
Right, what do we want to do? I've already forgotten what I was gonna do. Um
Let's give her a make cruel
Tongue
And that's it. That's all she needs and then again, we'll just do the Belgian colors
Let's do a little bit of black
Then let's do a little bit of yellow
And let's do a little bit of red
And then oh, that's not even the spread though. It needs to be even or else. It doesn't look good right black
yellow
And red
Okay, there we go
And then she needs
thigh high socks
And you'll never guess what the color scheme of the thigh high socks are gonna be you're gonna absolutely
Hit your panty. Oh wait, hold on. I can just like draw it straight on it goes black
Pajama cut me through the tongue
See through I don't even get through that. Oh, I see in snow berries
Did I see finally talk about any childhood memory or did she just yap again about get about grooming you?
Oh
Then red no yellow
Yellow
High snowberries and daddas alike. I hope you guys are doing well. We're currently designing gen 2
We are doing the last design
Believe it or not. I've actually smoked this
But why not I take you through memory lane of what we've done just to recap really quickly
On what devious designs we've come up with. Okay
I'm not sure you're ready for it. But hey, oh, that's that's the fun in designing
Hello. Hi reader. Thank you for coming in
and
Just let me quickly right here we go. I will take you through so
Everyone wouldn't shut the f up about a freaking slime girl. So I made the ugliest slime girl possible. Her color scheme is blue white and
Magenta I guess her pupil shape is blue with a magenta drop. She's ugly as anything. I despise her
Her nickname is jar jar goops
Um, and her name is slimy slime McGee
And her catchphrase is misa join a V sucky. Okay
So this is her nice and ugly. This buys it. She's in a one-piece swimsuit
She's got a can of cola stuck in her thigh. Um, and there's absolutely she's got like this hideous tail
Uh, no, no, don't don't ruin it yet. She's got like this hideous tail going on. No idea why
Um, and when she cancels stream she goes. Oh my tummy hurts stream is cancelled
And it's because she has a fish in her stomach. That's magenta colored. Okay, so nice and ugly. We hate her
Uh, I'm surprised surprised. She's been rejected for the lineup. Unfortunately. I have very sad to report
um, and then we go over to
goth eye hop employee of the month um, uh, and oh see an oh
Oh ne san. Um, her pupils are an upside down cross that are black accentuated with a white outline
Um, and she's an eye hop thingy and her hat says I hop on your dick. Um
Are you squinting here?
Broly lit now make another one
No, I'm not touching slam girl again. I fucking despise it. I'm not doing it broly legend. Thank you for the tip
Um, her hat says I hop on your dick. She's got a one
Pleat thing. It's her hair is black, but it's got like this kind of purpley blue going through it
She has an infinite e-caller which you gave her because you know brother and sister
um, and her
Her catchphrase is let me serve you. Oh winky face xoxo. She has her name is hex
She has piercings. She has an eyebrow piercing. She's got a little love heart on her face
She's got a very tight fitting crop top
Um, and she's got just tight fitting shorts and she has long coffin shaped nails
Which has glove fishnet gloves and then fishnet tights all the way down to her little tozies
And she has one shoe because I gave up, but she's got fresh jays. I sure you okay
Actually good design now. You're just gassing me up. Okay next we have
um our mad scientist
her name is
uni ology
She has in a coat a lab coat. She has nothing going on up here
She has an irradiated pocket and she has a sort of sling like
Keeney mechanic going on
But some people would legit go for it
um
She has a little bikini thing going on over here her little tummies out and all that
This is the design underneath the lab coat that you don't see
Um, and for her shoes. She has steel toad regulated boots. They're fantastic. Absolutely fantastic
Her fringe is slicked back and she also has pre braces
Thank you fargon miss for the tip. Um, I'm glad you'd go for it. Um, she's on the booger sugar
She's following Freud's footsteps. Um, and she does unethical unethical testing on you and her pupil is a
DNA deoxy ribonucleic acid little helix double helix
Um
And her color scheme is green purple and white for the lab coat. Um, her eyes
And her hair all have the intertwining color
She also has braces as well and our twining colors. Um, and that is our little crazy lab scientist
And then we have our beloved
goblina, um
She's very into pray play. Um, and this is her pupil
Which is an egg an ovum and a little swimmer going inside. Um, her color scheme is
Uh, brown tan and green. I'm actually just gonna steal her hair right now and pop it in that box
Um, her nickname is gobby. Um, but her actual legal name on a piece of paper
I'm a spell Freud wrong. Uh, her legal name on a piece of paper is jumps a cox
Um, or noblin. Um, and her catchphrase is i'm always ready to ride
She's a little r wordy. So not very, uh, not very
Good to go, but she does have a womb tattoo. Um, it's an upside down heart
There's no actual heart in her womb tattoo because it's not always
Uh, you didn't always want that
um
Ignore the fact that aces hair is hiding right on top of her. She's got one tooth and she looks very
Um, nice
She looks very friendly and approachable, but uh, unfortunately that is not the reality once you actually get to know her because it's over for you
Um, her markings on her body again
She has markings that glow the more excited she get the more noticeable the markings are
Um, she has an ovum on her leg and she has a little swimmer
Um, and then she has the egg egg and then a very unique symbol that has never been done in history before very true very true
and she has sandals
Um, and uh, even though you may try and get away from her
You will always hear the sound of flip-flops approaching you doesn't really matter. Uh, what uh, necessary
stage we're at. Um
But her hair is a lighter brown on top and a gradient to a darker brown
And her clothing is rags that she put together because she doesn't really see the need for clothes. So there you go
um
And then we are working on the last design, which is our
discord kitten. Uh, she's belgian
Um, her pupils are like a head with nickel ears and then a pupil like an actual pupil
She has braces, but I had to remove it because she's doing the hegeo face
um
And she's got like a little side thing going on
And a little window that you can see actually I've not drawn the line. Oh, how could I forget the line?
Let's zoom right back in there. What do I think I'm doing?
Oh
six just like that
um
And then she's holding a fishy
Oh, sorry. Um, her tails. Oh, sorry and her tails got like the little
Um, pokemon on it. The pokemon's in her hair and we are just finishing off her legs and then we're done really
I think she be actually might be alive
Um, perfect timing
Perfect timing if you ask me
We're just gonna finish off her
Leggies because she's wearing she's really repping belgium. She she just loves her home country
Her catchphrase is male if you didn't know belgian people eat mayonnaise with chips
Um, and she wants your mayonnaise for her chips wink wink, uh, and that is her that's her story
Uh, she's sticking to it. She's not changing it, but she has a discord e can a discord
E girl at the end of the day. So, uh
Do with that information what you will
Sheepers is later tonight. Oh, no, I don't have anyone to read all right into
And then we go yellow
And then red and yellow
Unfortunately, I didn't get much sleep. So I don't my brain's actually shutting down right now
I can feel it. Um, I am gonna have a big sleep after stream, which I'm very happy about
Because I've been needing it. Um, I do have an update for bleeding hearts. Your audio will come out
When I wake up. It's already there. I just need to upload it. Um, it got edited
Thankfully not by me. I didn't have to do it, but I do have to edit my reef link one. Why is one leg?
Stalking getting longer than the other. What have I done here?
Um, yes, so for any bleeding hearts when I wake up, I need to sleep. I know. Oh, it's so quick and
Just upload it strong. You please. I'm literally dying my I'm taking hp damage doing this right now. Please have patience
I
Um
Yeah, you should redirect to strong here. She's doing a sleep stream
Bruh, if I didn't fart, I'd be doing so many sleep streams. You'd be sick of me
You'd honestly be sick of me
I'd be snoring away
Oh, no, she's like a bumblebee now sweet little bumblebee. Oh math. Thank you for why is your picture the
Venn diagram thing. Thank you math for the again tiff the mem. Wow. Why 10 gifted members?
I really struggle with it that those word combinations
Thank you math for the 10 gifted sub script
Memberships congrats to those who caught it with your face. Um
Why is your thing the Fibonacci sequence?
I'm so curious
No, we let do it braffin up his thorn
That'd be real funny. Nice. Yes. We haven't heard. Oh my emotions are about to come
I'm just waiting for them to actually send me the files now. Her toes are sadly going to be covered up
It's a sacrifice. I'm willing to make okay
Are you squinting me right now?
Do do them. We don't mind the two. I am not
I say that as if Amy didn't send me clips of her farting so we can turn them into shorts
Honestly, it may is such a good sport. I was like explaining to the girls
I was like if you have her fart on stream, please let me know so I can turn it into shorts
Because it always gets popular for like no reason
I get super popular
So I'm literally sent away a highlight clip of me forcing out a fart. She was trying so hard. I was like, yeah, dang
And then the toes are going to be red. Oh
We did it
Jane too has been confirmed
Look at our little belgian discord kitten thing. Yay
Fart a little golden ratio. Vendai, aren't true socks that show toes and the ball with the foot. That's just a zura
Yui did it. Yeah, I suppose people find it even
Fart is when you melt
honestly
Thank you again for the game. Diff the member
Why can I not say 10 gifted memberships? Thank you math 16 18 for that again. That's where it kind of you
Uh
That shimmers aren't unreachable
Jen too confirmed codename. What codename would you give this Jen?
We've got hexa bacon. We've got uniology
We've got jumpsacock
Oh, we did we give kids discord kitten a name?
Maybe we'll just call her kitten like spell it like that kitten kitten
And then we've got slimy slimy ghee
um
I think I mean she's shutting down. I'm shutting down
I mean, it's all right. Uh, I would probably be
If I had to pick my favorite
I actually like
Who'd I like the most?
Lower wise. I like the goblin
Um
Design wise the most potentials probably uniology
kitten kaboot
Call the gen pintus because it was in gen two and chase honestly
Suicide freak score gen one a lure implies you have a choice
Let's name a gen two oblige because you don't have a choice gen two freaky
Personally attacked by the thumbnail
Stop
I'm freaking
Look, I had to draw a slime girl and it accidentally makes jar jar binks as a freaking slime girl was terrible
but this is
This is gen two
It's quite an interesting lineup. We've got going on after admit you would like the goblin. Yeah
Maybe I would I made her myself
The goblin's actually just me for real for real. Maybe remove the chest
Everything else. Yeah, sure. I'll take it
Wait if on the Belgian girl get her stockings warmer toes in their feet shape toes and have toes on
Why are you I'm too tired to even translate what you've just tried to communicate to me gen two
I'm sorry. She will never be slimed didn't the thumbnail say no slim girl jar jar slime basically
Yes, the thumbnail said no slime girls. I was gonna get harassed. So we made one
I made the ugliest slime girl imaginable. So you'll stop asking for a slime girl. We're not getting a slime girl
The goblin is really good. Yeah, you like the concept of the goblin. Yeah
Okay
Yeah, the r-word goblin that's literally called jumps on your cock. Jeez
I'm thinking of an android girl that could have a attachment
Wow
That's so good aneurysm
I think we did it
Sheebie, how do you not be live right now because I don't think I can redirect into you
I don't know when you're popping on
Out of raw curiosity, let me go have a swatch at you. When are you coming on then?
Do you sheebie?
Sheebie, sheebie, sheebie, sheebie
Oh
No, yeah, oh you've not got your shoes up for the week. Oops
Oh, you're doing a membership watch along
right
I'm the slam girl what you bagsy jar jar slime. Sure. You want jar jar slime all yours. I I'll take the goblin. Okay
Yeah
Emi technically is the Belgian one because she speaks French. She's doing a membership. How dare you
Goblin for gen two and three what you want to do that are fucking hell bent on
Getting pregnant. What's going on here? Wait, no one's online that I'm subscribed to that's something
Not one person
What is hooker haze? I keep seeing that game everywhere. It looks like it's a new game like came out
He's got hay
It's deep inside of me
Girl you just don't realize
Oh you hold
In your arms so tight you let me know
Everything's all right. Rhea's gonna play it. When does Rhea come live?
Cuz I'm
Hooked on gen two
Um
They're no even here. Yeah, bum bum bum
But they are in love with me
Cuz I'm their mommy
It's rather weird because I'm actually younger than a lot of them, but it's okay with me
Because I love my daughter
Well, there's no one online
So I'm not gonna redirect
Cuz no one's coming online
for another
couple
Boom boom boom. It's not unusual
Cuz I don't need no slain
From from I should stay
afflicted
By the Belgian discord
Can
Oh the good love
Oh you turn me on
Give it up goblin are the mad scientists cuz I'm
In love with Oni san bum bum bum
I gave her a color bum bum bum
And she's in love with me
But it's a big old secret between two consenting adults
There's my gen that's my gen
We did it. I'm gonna go pass out. I need to sleep
Yay, I have accepted four designs
One is being rejected
Tada
She made a slim girl just to exclude her. Yep. You got it. Okay. I'm I'm gonna go pass out
Uh, I'll go redirect into rea, but rea isn't online for another hour
But that's okay because you can do what you want
Honestly, are you squid me or who goes there identify yourself
Stronger go to bed this instant or I will be cutting you off from anything until you get eight hours of sleep
Yeah
my ink
I I think
I need the ink
Or else for the inconvenience you caused me to be
dry of ink
I will
For something. I don't know. What do people do for punishment?
I'm going to bed. Why are you so prejudiced against just the differently consistent?
Look, are you squid me or gas there's solids and there's the rest
I will I may I may just have a good rest. What are you gonna do about it?
You're gonna make me pump up the jam pump it up pump while your feet are still bumping or something like that
Oh, wait, I need to say thank you for the donors and then I can go off
Because that's what streamer etiquette is all about. That's right. You give me money and I say your name
You give me money. I will put even more girls. How do you right? Thank you very much
Oh, and it's broken. Oh, no, there is thank you very much
And on for the tip and tiny spiny for the tip. I'm going to bed. I'm going to go for a nice 12 hours sounds good to me
Haha
I'm gonna go bed. Are you guys gonna be okay on your own?
I feel like I've not done much
Are you gonna be okay reef links?
I'm a little worried, but I think you're okay. Can you hold the fort for like
12 hours? Wait. No, I see you in 22 hours
I can't do that. Okay
Okay, thank you reef link. I will see we'll be fine. You're the one who needs to sleep. Okay. I will get sleep for once
I will give you one kiss for every girl that has been accepted into gen two
Oh, you get spout on
Don't ever say slime girl around me again
Oh
Okay, all done. I kissed the mole a little extra. Okay, and then for you be fun
A little bit tongue
Okay, I'll see you tomorrow
Yes, I will not so streaming works. Are you squinting me right now?
Stroney, you go bed. I will be fine. Go to bed or you will get a spanking. Okay. Oh wait
You didn't vote one more thing one more thing one more thing one more thing one more thing one more thing one more thing
Ha ha ha ha ha
Just give me one more chance
Who has your vote
That's not his vote. Wait, that's a q&a. Gosh darn it. That's not a q&a
That's the poll
Who has your vote?
Belgium
Who's hate that you can't say that kind of stuff
What are you a scientist?
What are you
On sugar. Sure. Well, yeah, yeah, or then big sister server
Yeah, boom go
Who's got your vote? Thank you brilliant legend for the pair. Who's got your vote? Come on. What design's best?
I have all the designs who's best
I'm not stalling I want to know you don't want to tell me who you like
Oh wow the goblina
Ha
Shawnee you missed one. I absolutely did not miss one. These are all the girls
You can vote now to tell me who you like the most. It was like goblina's winning
Where's the slain jar jar bang? No
Okay, it seems like I need to work on some sort of
Precious I'm sorry
I freaking love goblina's. Oh, that's a blue one go to bed. Fine. I'll go bed
Okay, okay one more kiss and then I'll go a bit
Will you be good riflin don't make me worry about you when I'm asleep, okay
I'm gonna go sleep for like a solid eight hours. I'm gonna take drugs to make sure I I sleep even extra. Okay
And then when I have a big massive sleep, I will have an amazing sleep
And then I will wake up and I will be so motivated to edit all these asmr's for you
Because I love editing asmr's but I get very tired. You just spit on us. I spat on you for the for the the
Slame but no spinning, you know
Only thing I'm spitting on is yuck yuck so I can slurp on it. Anyway, I'm gonna go bed. I'll leave it there
10 out of 10
Blocks kiss. Oh, you're an icy fan. So that's different
Tee
Right. Good
night
Good night
Thank you for
watching
mainstream
It's how vanyao
I love you rifling. Please look after yourself. Please don't make me worried and when I wake up. I will
Cup your bowls. Thank you. I'll be here all week. Good night riflings. Bye
Bye